[Music]
breaking news this Thursday night an
accused murderer in Manitoba now facing
more charges and the four victims are
all indigenous women there's someone's
daughter someone's sister someone's
mother someone's friend Canada's new
National dental plan for children this
is really going to be life-changing
who's eligible what the plan will
better protect your privacy at home as
smart devices become more popular and
Team Canada says bye bye to the World
Cup we look ahead to the goals for 2026.
global national with Donna Friesen good
evening and thanks for joining us we
begin with an expanding murder
investigation in Winnipeg a suspect
already in custody and charged with one
murder is now charged with three
additional counts of first-degree murder
all of the victims are indigenous women
and the details of the cases are deeply
disturbing parts of the first victim to
be named Rebecca Contour were found in a
dumpster and a Winnipeg landfill site
the bodies of the other women Morgan
Beatrice Harris and Mercedes Myron have
yet to be found along with a fourth
victim who has not yet been identified
police are appealing to the public for
help Melissa region is following this
for us from Winnipeg
while 24 year old Rebecca cantwa's
murder lasts May was the first to put
Jeremy Sabiki on police radar they say
she was actually the final victim
Winnipeg Police say they've charged
kabiki with three new murders the first
is an unknown woman in her 20s they
showed a jacket believed to be connected
with that woman hoping it can be linked
to a missing person second was 39 year
old Morgan Harris who was reported
missing last May the third was 26 year
old Mercedes Myron who went missing last
March I don't know if they were
specifically being targeted but clearly
the victims in this are all indigenous
women Harris and Myron are from long
plane First Nation an hour west of
Winnipeg their families declined to
speak to media and asked through an
advocate for privacy to come to grips
with what they've learned it's
devastating news for long plane First
Nation and chief Kira Wilson
she is also a part of my extended family
as well so there is a connection for
myself with my family and my community
for the three identified women that they
spoke of today investigators say they
haven't recovered the bodies of the
three new victims but believed they were
killed around at the same time in May
and they don't believe there are other
victims these charges bring Winnipeg's
homicide toll to 50 so far this year
surpassing the previous record of 44 in
2019 at least 11 of the victims in this
year's homicides are indigenous women
that is a stat that missing murdered
indigenous women and girls Advocates say
is unacceptable Donna
Melissa Ridge in Winnipeg thanks if you
or someone you know is in need of
support you can call
1-844-413-6649 this is a national
toll-free Crisis Line available 24 7 for
anyone who requires emotional assistance
related to missing and murdered
indigenous women
now to the crisis inside hospitals in
this country a crushing wave of
respiratory viruses continues to
overwhelm children's hospitals and the
scramble to treat those kids is
undermining health care for adults Ross
Lorde reports
for Canada's most vulnerable the Health
crisis known as the triple demick is
terrifying every time Cohen coughs
um I get a a shot of anxiety
two-year-old Cohen Peery of Burlington
Ontario struggles with chronic lung
disease and Asthma Cohen is a frequent
visitor to hospital emergency
departments which are being overrun by
covid RSV and flu patients for his most
recent emergency the piries waited for
two days in the ER people receiving care
in the hall and the waiting room is just
packed it's it's chaos Health Canada's
tracking of Cold and Flu illnesses has
seen a jump in the last 10 weeks the
records are available with influenza
cases spiking far above expected levels
for this time of year managing care for
so many sick children is now leaving
some adults in danger that days coming
where the pain is going to return and it
scares me in Winnipeg Stephanie Sanders
was receiving infusions that eased her
painful endometriosis but staff at her
pain clinic are being reassigned to help
with a wave of children suffering from
respiratory viruses it's hard knowing
how many of us
will or might go back to the pain we are
doing
for because of getting the treatment the
somewhat encouraging news Health Canada
says RSV is stabilizing but for now
doctors and nurses say they're barely
hanging on for influenza in particular
you know for the patients that we
actually test at the end of October we
were seeing a positivity rate of 10
percent in terms of the patients that we
actually got a sample and had it tested
in our lab that is up to 30 which is a
significantly High number all of this as
parents across Canada struggle with a
persistent shortage of children's pain
medication the shortage Health Canada
says it's addressed and says
distribution of foreign labeled products
is underway Cohen Perry's parents say
he's doing better and they're doing
whatever they can to avoid future ER
visits Ross Lord Global News
a long promise Federal dental care
benefit for children is now available
for parents to apply for it's for
children under the age of 12 who don't
have access to private dental insurance
the plan is part of a compromise made
with the NDP who have agreed to support
the liberal minority government but are
still demanding a National dental plan
for all uninsured Canadians Marnie blunt
reports on the plan's details and its
challenges
for many a trip to the dentist is
routine but for numerous Canadian
families that's not the case it's up to
about a million children right now who
do not have dental coverage and now the
federal government is going to help
families access Affordable Dental Care
parents across the country are now going
to be able to afford to send their kids
to the dentist the new benefit a
compromise between the Liberals and the
NDP as part of an agreement that will
see the new Democrats support the
minority government until 2025. this
could help kids have healthier smiles
have healthier oral health which will
mean that they'll be better off for
their long term this is really going to
be life-changing so who can apply the
5.3 billion dollar plan would see
families with an annual income of ninety
thousand dollars or less qualify for the
benefit and are able to receive 260 to
650 dollars per child under the age of
12. families who already have private or
employer-provided coverage are not
eligible
the Ontario Dental Association welcomed
the news but says more work needs to be
done and provincial governments need to
step up in a statement to Global News
the conservative Shadow Health Minister
said most provinces and territories
already have low-income dental programs
and called the new benefit inflationary
spending we do have problems currently
with the provincial dental plans in this
province there are five provincial
dental plans they are all chronically
underfunded and they are not meeting the
needs of the people on these programs
but allowing more people to access care
means increased pressures at the dental
office
and like every uh basic employment
sector we're all facing some challenges
and particularly for dental assistants
across the country the federal
government is still working on a wider
National dental care program that will
include children under the age of 18
seniors and people living with
disabilities the timeline for that phase
is the end of 2023. Marty blunt Global
News Ottawa
some good news for thousands of Canadian
workers dealing with illness starting
today federally regulated private sector
workplaces are now required to provide
10 days paid sick leave to all employees
at the end of the month workers who have
been continuously employed for at least
30 days will have access to their first
three days of paid sick leave
in Quebec three members of the National
Assembly defied a long-standing
tradition and as a result were denied
entry into the legislature today they
refused to swear the oath of office to
King Charles III a requirement under the
Canadian Constitution they're all
members of the party quebecois and they
call that oath humiliating Dan Spector
is following this for us from Quebec
City Dan this played out in front of the
cameras walk us through what happened
Donna a dramatic scene at the National
Assembly this morning weeks in the
making the PQ pulling a real stunt as
they defied the tradition every elected
member pledges their allegiance to the
people of Quebec and the monarchy when
they're sworn in 122 out of 125 Quebec
mnas did so but the three separatists
Pepsi quebecois members have been
steadfast in refusing to pledge their
allegiance to King Charles III they had
hoped to find another way in asking the
new speaker of the assembly to change
the rules to allow them to sit in the
chamber but she didn't so we ended up
with a moment where they walked up to
the door a crowd had gathered countless
cameras watching to see exactly what
would happen and they were shut out
party leader plamondon spoke to the
Sergeant at Arms presented his
credentials but the answer remained no
there was no Struggle No physical force
needed they did leave peacefully but as
of now they cannot enter the Blue Room
to vote on laws to present motions or
ask questions to the premier here's the
party leader on why he refuses to take
the oath
it's a humiliation
and a reminder that we never chose our
political system that continues from a
generation to another
in our
so at some point it has to stop and it
has to change in spite of the
embarrassment this is actually turning
into a win for the PQ members of all
parties now expressing how they don't
like taking the oath either and Premier
Francois Legos saying next week his
party is going to present a new bill to
make it optional so it seems they will
get their way although it could take a
while until they're allowed into the
chamber Donna all right Dan Specter in
Quebec City thanks
a royal AIDS racist remarks coming up
the Fallout after an incident between a
lady in waiting and a guest at the
palace
[Music]
[Applause]
The Prince and Princess of Wales are on
a tour of the U.S and at this Boston
Celtics game last night they heard
chance of USA and a smattering of booze
when they were introduced it is their
first visit to the U.S in eight years
and it coincides with a story about
racism back home at Buckingham Palace a
former lady in waiting to Queen
Elizabeth resigned because of what she
said to a black guest at the palace
Crystal gemancing on the Royal tour and
the tensions
helps African and Caribbean domestic
abuse survivors but it wasn't her work
that Drew questions at Buckingham Palace
where are you really from
I'm really from here
yeah but okay so
I can see that this is going to be a bit
of a challenge she said
what's your nationality
and I said lady I was born here I'm
British the charity leader was one of a
few hundred invited guests of the queen
consort the reception on Tuesday was in
honor of the UN day for the elimination
of violence against women fellani was
standing with two others when the woman
who she did not name touched her hair
and engaged her in what she likened to
an interrogation I experienced racism
in an environment that I should have
felt safe in Lady Susan Hussey a
longtime companion of the late Queen and
godmother to the Prince of Wales later
resigned from her position as a royal
aide last year allegations of
institutional racism were raised by
Meghan Markle but she was dismissed with
many calling her an attention-seeking
troublemaker
the house of Windsor is back in the
spotlight with a trailer dropping for
the six-part Netflix special featuring
The Duke and Duchess of Sussex no one
sees what's happening behind closed
doors the show promotion overshadowing
the future King's first American visit
in eight years
Prince William and his wife Kate were
hoping attention would be lavished on
Friday's award ceremony for the Earth
shot prize instead his brother and the
palace Scandal are pulling Focus prime
minister Rishi sunak who has also had
his britishness challenge based on his
skin color says the country is making
progress
Crystal gemancing Global News London
privacy protection ahead keeping your
personal data safe in a world of smart
technology
[Music]
if you still have cable and you pay for
some of the many streaming services you
know how expensive watching TV can be as
Mike relay reports a new option is
emerging it's called fast that stands
for free ad supported streaming
television it's becoming more popular in
the US and now it's coming to Canada
just when you thought you'd figured out
TV streaming services Here Comes Pluto
it's fast as in free ad supported
streaming television a trend that's been
around for a few years in the U.S but is
now being introduced to Canadian viewers
what we do is you know we create we
program the channels for uh for them we
in a way trying to solve the products of
Choice by bringing well-created linear
channels to the end users unlike
streaming services like Netflix Amazon
and crave where videos are exclusively
streamed on demand Pluto run by
Paramount in the US and Global TV parent
company chorus in Canada will have
channels dedicated to specific shows
both old and new as well as the news all
of which will run 24 7. CBC launched its
own fast Channel this week called
explore viewers will have lots of choice
minus some flexibility and while there
will be commercial breaks the app is
completely free free is a good price for
the users and they will need to watch
some ads in exchange of really
qualitative premium content the
advertising element is the one industry
Watchers in Canada are Keen to see play
out will Millennials who have become
accustomed to getting what they want
when they want it sit through a
two-minute commercial break but I guess
I'm a bit of a doubter because I think
people now that are involved with and
like streaming one of the main reasons
they like streaming is because they
don't have to deal with advertising
viewers aren't watching TV the same way
they were 40 years ago and while choice
is a good thing it can also be expensive
what Canadians buy into what Pluto is
offering they don't have to it's free
microlight Global News Toronto
technology is such a part of our Lives
now we hardly even notice how Reliant we
are on it many of us have multiple
artificially intelligent helpers
assisting us with things like turning on
the lights vacuuming and regulating the
temperature in the first story of a
global news series automation nation and
gaviola looks at the Automation in our
daily lives and how to protect your
privacy
when you think of robots what probably
Springs to mind is a scene like an
Amazon warehouse teeming with thousands
of robotic workers hey Google play The
Beatles
[Music]
robots in our home come in two
categories actual robots that dust and
clean and interact physically and
intelligent Bots that play music help us
manage grocery lists show us who's at
the door control the temperature both
types can save us time and money we
ended up saving close to two hundred
dollars on on our annual gas bill and
that only got better in the years after
that but according to robotics expert
William melick government rules
protecting consumers and their valuable
information is lagging I think the
technology is ahead of policy in terms
of basically how this is structured
properly and framework in such a way
that will guarantee not only product
quality but ensuring end user or
consumer privacy and protection of
personal information there are ways to
manage your risk for example the robot
vacuum that knows the layout of your
home probably doesn't need to be
connected to a server the first thing
you really want to know is whether it is
possible to use this device in in a
non-smart mode whether it is possible to
use it without it being connected to the
internet the Neato family keeps their
four smart speakers in high traffic
areas where they're less likely to catch
private conversations for added privacy
and security they use a VPN service for
connected devices experts warn that as
robots and intelligent Bots for home use
become more accessible and convenient
keeping them separate and keeping an eye
on how they use our personal data will
become even more challenging and gaviola
Global News Toronto
learning experience next what team
Canada can take away from their World
Cup experience
[Music]
Canada's trip to the World Cup has come
to an end the team is heading home
without a win having lost today to
Morocco Canada did get a goal but it was
an own goal scored by a Moroccan player
the ball was deflected by a Moroccan
player and ended up in his own team's
net it still counts as a goal for Canada
but we ended up losing two to one
wrapping up the Canadian men's first
time back at the World Cup in 36 years
watching it all unfold was Joshua cloak
he's a staff writer for the athletic who
is in Qatar Joshua is also author of The
voyagers a book about the rise of
Canada's men's team Josh
how you doing this is not the outcome
Canada was hoping for but what about
their Spirit at the game today
look I thought their spirit in the
second half in particular uh was great
you know they go down 2-0 in particular
because of some poor goalkeeping and
support offending and a lot of teams
would probably throw in the towel at
that point but you know Canada's
resilience has certainly become their
calling card as a team and I think
they've tried to really close that
qualitative Gap that exists between
really good teams like Belgium Croatia
and Morocco with that resilience and and
that's what they did there was some good
tactical adjustments in the second half
but to me it was that ability to to
fight back that really stood out but
ultimately again
it's that qualitative Gap in that
experience that teams like Morocco have
that Canada doesn't have that I think
was really the difference on you know a
night like tonight and ultimately
throughout the entire world cup yeah
they must have gained so much experience
from just being there right how would
you describe their overall performance
in the tournament what did they get
right and how does it set them up for
the World Cup in 2026
look Canada came into this world cup
with a few goals they wanted to be the
first team in Canadian history to score
a men's World Cup goal to play Fearless
football to get a result and to get out
of the group they scored a goal they
played Fearless football but they didn't
get out of the group and they didn't get
a result so I think you know objectively
you do have to call this world cup a bit
of a failure and you have to hope that
come 2026 they'll have the confidence
knowing what these games are like and
they'll be able to know this is how we
close games out because that's not what
they showed in this world cup Canada
automatically qualifies for the 2026
World Cup because the games are in North
America do you think we'll see many of
the same players then and some new
Rising Stars
yeah absolutely if you're Canada and the
Canadian coaching staff you have to feel
bolstered by the fact that your best
players right now are your youngest
players taejean Buchanan is only 23
years old and he was Canada's best
player throughout the tournament he
should move even higher up the football
ladder Alfonso Davies only 22 we know
what he is he's Canada's best men's
player of all time uh Jonathan David is
just 23 and he should be in a top 12 top
15 club in the world and that kind of
experience that those players are going
to Garner is going to help them in 2026.
all right Joshua cloak in dohad thank
you
thank you
that is global national for this
Thursday I'm Donna Friesen tonight's
your candidate is the magic of lights
display at rad torque Raceway in Ladue
County Alberta we would love to see your
festive and joyful pictures this time of
year you can email yours to viewers at
globalnational.com thanks for watching
Jeff Semple will be at the anchor desk
tomorrow and I will see you on Saturday
for the new reality bye-bye
[Music]
thank you